the director of the National Museum of
Afghanistan summed up much of what we
are thinking about at the moment in
particular with the words a nation stays
alive when its culture stays alive and
what we're witnessing particularly in
the last few weeks is a systematic
attempt to destroy culture and redefine
national boundaries what I'm going to
now talk about are some case studies and
experiences and positive experiences of
working with the National Museum of
Afghanistan in over the last few years
in particular and to describe what can
be done perhaps in connection with other
countries looting is has been endemic in
Afghanistan probably since the late 60s
is well documented through the 70s
declined during the period of the Soviet
occupation rose again dramatically
during the civil war in the chaos that
ensued when the museum's were also
targeted fell under the Taliban years it
seems but was replaced by annika
iconoclastic destruction in the last
year of Taliban rule of a size and scale
very similar to what we're witnessing
today in Iraq and Syria there were many
attempts by particular by private
individuals to try and safeguard and
record Afghan cultural heritage but
official governmental responses I think
it has to be said were generally very
slow and late and really followed the
fall of the Taliban government in 2001
in 2006 the icon red list was finally
launched in London turning to a sister
institution of this on the occasion of
an exhibition at the British Museum in
2011 those the opportunity to sign an
official Memorandum of Understanding
between the relevant
directors of the British Museum and the
National Museum in Kabul and to
formalize our intent to work very
closely together on the issue of stolen
cultural heritage whether it be from
museums in Afghanistan or from
archaeological sites so I'll run through
three case studies because I know you've
only got a few minutes the first case
study revolved around a group of 20 of
the famous by Graham ivories lost from
the museum in Kabul during the Civil War
disappeared on to the black market
tracked down by a private individual
reacquired for the museum in Kabul with
the blessing of that museum conserved
and analyzed by us at the Museum in
London and returned by us to Kabul and
the end of last year we were very
pleased to announce and present in Kabul
the full publication of the work we did
with our colleagues there the second
case study revolves around another
famous object the largest piece of
gander and sculpture from the museum in
Kabul which was taken one night from
open display there during the Civil War
disick Rick disappeared across borders
into a country that is not a signatory
of UNESCO into a private collection its
whereabouts was communicated through us
to the director of the National Museum
in Kabul who gave the go-ahead for it to
be acquired by any means necessary it
lay beyond the power of law or UNESCO
and so a private individual did
something which is often frowned on he
went and bought it because the owner
would not give it back and could not be
compelled to give it back he went and
bought it and here iam ported it into
Britain it was taken from the airport
straight to
museum where I was inspected by curators
from Kabul verified it still had its
museum number on I have to say we
exhibited it temporarily in order to
maximize press attention on this event
and it is now back on display in Kabul
the third case study revolves around a
different type of problem which is a
much more large-scale and much more
difficult problem and that's the looting
of archaeological sites which has been
endemic now in Afghanistan for decades
now over the years in the last decade
and a half thousands of objects which we
believe in British Museum to originate
in Afghanistan have been seized by UK
border force with the assistance of
particular lens team and the art and
antiques unit of the mat and the HMRC
we've cataloged them and we have
returned them to Kabul is as two great
big consignments of objects this process
has involved a lot of people it's
involved a lot of organizations
including NGOs and the Red Cross and
it's involved British Armed Forces also
in returning large quantities of
material in a safe way we've also been
very anxious to make sure that the
recording of those objects before
they're sent back is done to a
relatively high standard that we hand
back condition reports of those objects
and that we are fully transparent in
what has been sent back and this is
again from the wishes of Kabul who have
given us the green light to publish a
full catalogue of what we've said so
that is my last closing slide showing
the Buddha from sarai kuja back on
display beautiful display in Kabul and
the press release on fifth of August
2012 when you can see some of the bag
ram ivories and looted p
is going on display in Kabul so clearly
there are lessons to be learned from
working together and I'm talking museum
to museum organization to organization
across international boundaries and
involving private individuals and the
trade as well to identify catalog and
where possible repatriate pieces to
countries of origin thank you